I think this is something like the Cam
Newton publicity tour for me right now
it would be hey Kim every other day
release video of you doing workouts and
you doing drills and doing things like
that to show everybody like hey 1 you're
working but 2 that your body is
functioning at a high level yeah I think
there's something to that if I'm his
agent or anybody you know in his camp
that would be something I would make an
effort to do right now is yes you know
daily few times a week whatever it may
be we're gonna release content on you
cam and have some cameras here to make
NFL executives the people the media
everybody get a good look at you to go
hey the guy's healthy he's ready to go
now who wants his services because you
know I'm like you I think what he's
healthy he's dangerous and no matter
what teams he on he got a chance to win
when Cam Newton's your quarterback
remember when Johnny Manziel showed up
for his pro day workout at Texas A&M six
years ago and he had a helmet and
shoulder pads on remember that remember
how kind of gravy that was what the next
Cam Newton video should be full pads
show us that you are still the guy that
you always have been
it's one thing to see him doing it in
street clothes put on I mean I'm Todd
and you know we will I don't know how
people would react to that but to the
extent that you want to convince people
your back go all the way back put on the
pads let us feel like it's the same guy
who can move around now like he always
did cuz if this guy's now he's one of
the best quarterbacks in the NFL and
what the hell of the charge is waiting
for and I think with more of these
videos Chris I think we're on to
something here with more of these videos
somebody's going to pull the trigger on
this guy yeah I mean the problem is and
what we really haven't talked about here
Mike and you know I know I brought it up
when it first happened but the big thing
the elephant in the room and it just
didn't get enough attention in my
opinion it's Carolina screwed over Cam
Newton I mean they screwed him you know
I just feel like if other quarterbacks
got treated the way Cam Newton just got
treated where oh hey free agency started
hey look for a trade a lot of the other
spots have been filled already but go
ahead and look for a train now I mean
I'm sorry it makes me wanna curse I'm
gonna just say it's BA
there's what it is for a guy who has
clearly been the best player or at least
the most notable player on the history
of that franchise the fact that they
waited so late to figure out what to do
with Cam Newton it bothers me I can't
lie about that and now yeah who else is
there Mike I don't know it's the
Chargers or bust right now or it's wait
till training camp or wait till a team
reevaluate their situation I really
don't know but I do think it kind of
pisses me off that Carolina did that to
Cam Newton Peter King and I talked about
this on Friday you know the day that you
were home but you weren't working as
opposed to today where you're home and
you're working and and we you know I
pointed out the Greg Olson contrast that
they cut Greg Olson right after the
Super Bowl they knew they weren't going
to keep him they didn't try to to create
a trade market for him they didn't and
and I think cutting Greg Olson right
after the Super Bowl was part of the
effort to get a trade for Cam Newton
because hey they didn't cut Cam Newton
they must be keeping him maybe if we
want him we need to trade for him and
they just they hung on to that trade
possibility for way too long there's a
point where you just have to accept it's
not happening and we're gonna let the
guy go and I think when you're at the
Scouting Combine and you're selling this
idea that Matt rule the new coach of the
Panthers can't wait to coach Cam Newton
that was the moment we all should have
been throwing the challenge flag saying
wait a minute wait a minute this is all
baloney you're trying to get somebody to
offer you something this week it didn't
happen that's when they should have cut
him the exactly that gives you a way to
let it play out for the month of
February see if anybody shows any
interest and if as of March 1 they don't
drop the facade quit the ruse move on
and let the guy have a fair chance to
land somewhere else and the only reason
I can think they held him is because
they wanted to wait to get teddy
bridgewater bird in hand before they let
cam go but they weren't gonna keep him
anyway Chris nobody thought they were
gonna keep him no I know and you know
Mike I think you're correct and in your
little timeline there yeah once you got
to the end of February you should you
should have by that time had plenty of
time and opportunity to meet talked to
different teams about trade
possibilities anything like that once
you got to that
February early March you're right that
should have been the time where they
shoulda said okay cam figure out what
you're gonna do or we're gonna make you
a free agent or you know let your camp
and your agent call around teams to try
to figure out a trade but just the way
Cam Newton reacted he didn't want this
it didn't seem like he totally expected
this and I just don't think it's a good
look for the Carolina Panthers right now
but the way they treated them and yes
they've handcuffed it and now you know
to further the conversation what are the
Chargers do you know the Chargers
probably yes we know they were like you
know flirting with the Tom Brady idea
but you know anybody I talked to in the
know in the NFL definitely thinks the
Chargers are thinking about taking a
quarterback in the top ten of their the
draft and now they just got to figure
out do they want to take a quarterback
in the top ten and start something with
the future of their franchise or do they
want to go the Cam Newton route and say
hey let's roll the dice and see if the
guys healthy and maybe if he is we got a
quarterback for the next three four or
five years so those are the things that
I think why we're not going to hear a
lot about this right now because the
Chargers are probably going to try to
figure out their plan of attack going
forward and if they want the quarterback
what the plan is and if they don't want
the quarterback in the draft and they lo
Cam Newton what's the plan there so they
need to figure out what plan is best for
their organization
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports